[Applause]
hello everyone
thanks for coming to our talk what the
facts let's do some nineteen eighties
hacking party yeah so my name is Yaniv
bulma's and here is a young it cane we
are bought security researcher as a walk
for checkpoint research and let's begin
with a brief history of facts so it was
it all started in 1846 when a scientist
named Alexander Bain invented a center
first image of a wire and just a fun
fact this happened around 20 years
before the invention of the light bulb
and then facts evolved a bit and came to
be this machine's again just before the
invention of the telephone radio fakes
facts came to be and then in 1966 a
small company called Xerox invented the
first commercial fax machines and really
change the way we send electronic
documents from one to each other and
then throughout the years there was few
standards for fax but at 1980 the last
and most recent standards for fax came
to be by an organization called ITU and
namely the protocols are t-38 e46 those
are practically the same protocols we
still use today when we send fax and now
you know this was in the past but what's
happening today I mean let's compare we
have better ways to send aleko
electronic documents who want to to
other right let's compare fax to just
one of them let's say email right so if
we compare fax to email and just to
remind you we are comparing this to this
right so in terms of quality you've just
sold pictures you know I have nothing to
add in terms of accessibility I'm pretty
sure most or all of you have 24 by 7
axis
females right I'm not so sure you're
carrying around your fax machines with
you in terms of reliability so when you
send an email it gets received but you
know when it's in the fax it might get
accidentally shredded the dog might
might eat it or you know you can never
know or if it got to its destination and
in terms of authenticity well we can
argue about email whether or not it's
authenticated but we do have extensions
like public key cryptography what we
don't have is we have nothing for fax
simply no authentication at all so yeah
looking at this table you might think
okay so it's 2018 who is using fax
probably nobody is using right wrong fax
is pretty much live in kicking still
it's being used all over the place
ships maritime use it to receive those
critical Maps in open seas according to
Wikipedia 90% of the Japanese population
use fax well they really like fax over
there but I don't know why yeah but
they're Japanese so and if you do a lot
of Google combos like you know contact
us and fax you'll find over 300 million
fax numbers published on Google and
that's just the published numbers think
about how many fax machines don't have
the publish numbers out there so it's
simply a huge amount of fax numbers and
fax machines out there today and the
thing is that it's not only how many fax
machines are other but it's also who
uses fax well if you're a small
cooperate or a huge cooperate you have a
fax number you don't necessarily receive
faxes over this number but you do have a
fax number and it's published out there
if you're a bank they love faxes in
banks right so this is Bank of China the
biggest bank in the world with over
three point six two trillion dollars in
assets and that's their fax number and
maybe most importantly government
offices use fax if you ever wanted to
fax
our beloved the Donald Trump this is
this fax number which is Google it it's
there so the thing is that sometimes all
banks and healthcare and government
agencies they don't only allow you to
send fax but it's actually man
taury to send fax you can under either
use postal mail or fax to send them
information it's a good thing that they
took mail pigeons out of it but you know
so yeah it's a thing and when you're
thinking about it well you're thinking
probably what the fax I mean it's 2018
we should evolve to better ways of
electronic document delivery right and
now see this is how fax looks like today
well it's no longer this standalone fax
machines that we used to have twenty or
thirty years ago
right today fax is embedded this all
protocols are embedded within newer
technologies we have fax to email
services as I said we have fax of a
radio and fax over satellite and we have
I think most commonly these all-in-one
printers they have a lot of things right
and they come pre equipped with fax
functionality in them and now let's take
a look at this only one printers for a
second and if you think of it from a
security point of view there are just
black boxes right and those black boxes
has interfaces on one side they have
interfaces like Wi-Fi USB bluetooth
Ethernet stuff like that those
interfaces connects us to the internal
network or to the external network or
basically they connect us to the world
right and on the other hand we have
interfaces for connecting facts to the
phone line and those interfaces connects
us well to the 1970s something like that
and now this sounded interesting to us
and we thought okay let's imagine this
nice attack scenario right if you
consider those all-in-one printers are
at the end of the day nothing but
computers right they have memory they
have CPU just complete computers what
happens if an attacker with access to
the telephone line and equipped only
with its victims phone number will be
able to attack this printer just through
the telephone line and exploit this
printer and then take full control of it
right in this scenario it can then
propagate from the printer through any
one of the other interfaces let's say
the Internet to the internal network
right effectively creating a bridge
between the internal
work and the external network using the
telephone
that's 1980s again right so we thought
that's a really cool concept and we went
on and began the research for that and
after we got excited which sat down and
talked about the challenges we have and
it seems like we have quite a few
challenges in front of us and they are
really not simple so let's just name a
few of those challenges for example how
do we obtain the film were the code for
this printer how do we analyze the film
well once we got it what operating
system does this huge monsters are using
how can we be back this thing we have no
idea how does fax even work we just know
the beeping sounds but we have no idea
effects works and then after we
understand all that we need to
understand where should we look for
vulnerabilities inside this big big big
ecosystem so today we're gonna try and
take you through these questions one by
one until we'll be able to exploit this
printer right here on the table so let's
begin with how do we obtain the fumer
for printer so this is our printer I can
tell you a lot of things about why we
chose this printer but basically it's
the cheapest one so yeah we could afford
to break like four or five of those
doing the research so that was fun
actually we have a lot of ink and it's
really expensive so if you want
something will be able we'll be happy to
share so we need to break fax right but
just a minute before we break fax we
need to break the printer and I mean
literally break the printer that was the
fun part of the research we broke
everything up and try to look inside and
see what is this thing even built from
and this is basically the brain of the
printer that's how it looks like in the
inside from the inside let's go through
the major components of this PCB so it
has a flash rom manufactured by
expansion and then some more memory and
looking at that it looks a bit like some
components are missing right that's
mainly because the PCB has
sites so on the other side this is the
most interesting stuff like USB Wi-Fi
electricity SRAM this huge battery
that's used for something and then two
very interesting components one is the
main CPU that's a Marvel CPU and it's
manufactured specifically for HP by the
way I didn't mention that we chose HP
and not because we dislike HP but there
are just the biggest vendor they have
around 40% of the market share so they
look like a good target and then another
component is this component and this is
a fax modem
it's a CSP 1040 and we basically want to
focus our research on those two
components and understand how do they
work and what is the relation between
them so as I said one of the first
challenges will be to obtain the film
wear of this printer so we're taking a
closer look at this PCB and we find
these two very interesting interesting
things in here like it's serial debug
and a JTAG it's clearly marked on the
PCB so we say okay that's gonna be
really easy if you're not familiar with
them they are just interfaces that will
let you deep bug the the printer the CPU
read and write memory so that's
basically all we need to obtain the film
work unfortunately for us the JTAG is
completely disabled we can't access it
and the serial what we were able to
access the serial get is terminal but
almost every command we try to write
would give us this strange message I
don't understand what we don't
understand either so it seems like we're
not gonna go anywhere from here we need
to find an alternate path to get the
film work we looked a bit around and it
turns out that actually luckily for us
HP has this sites online an FTP site and
this site contains each and every few
more version for every HP product ever
produced in history that's a huge FTP
site it actually took us about two weeks
to find our film were within this mess
of humours but yeah finally we were able
to find this fumarole have our female
file yeah we can start work
but then we asked ourselves wait how do
you even upgrade the printer fumer have
have you ever done that I haven't so we
have this file we need to understand to
do that and the answer to this question
is surprisingly simple
well you just print it yeah you see HP
defined this standard called PCL Excel
future reference protocol class 2.1
supplement that if you are still sane
after reading this thing you understand
that the printer receives a pretty few
more up bridges the same way as it
receives a print job a normal print job
that's nice so cool and if we look at
the file that we got from this FTP site
this actually correlates pretty well
because you see it says pjl it stands
for print job language so now that we
know that we just need to decode this
fumer we're not going to take you to the
process of decoding this thing I'll just
give you the highlights this thing is
composed of a few decoding decoders like
serial C really aligned decoders like
null decoder TIF decoder Delta all
decoder there's a lot I can say about
them but they do something like you know
if the previous line was all spaces then
if this line is also all spaces just
write one instead of the line so you
will save some space now this makes a
lot of sense if you're talking about the
print job because you're expecting to
see a lot of empty lines in the in there
but when you're talking about binary
file it makes absolutely no sense to
encode it this way and to that we have
to say well if you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail and if
you're a printer everything looks like a
print job and okay we were finally able
to decode this thing and we got
ourselves what seems to be the few more
file and now we can finally start
working but how do we analyze this file
so we start looking at this file and
right in the beginning of it we see
something that looks like a table so
we're able to parse this thing and to
understand that it is a table and this
actually is a section table so it means
that the big file that we have is
actually composed of sack
and this table actually tells us stuff
like the loading address for each
section sorry the section name and the
location in binary and this basically
enables us to break this big file into
small sections and now we can inspect
each and every section specifically
there's one really big section in there
that we're really interested in because
it looks to be our actual femur and we
start to look at it and when we look at
that we see this now this looks
promising but something is not right
look at this this is the part of the
section it clearly says a heir or I
don't understand this is the same error
message we got from the serial port so
yeah that's probably the code that we
are looking for right but but it's not
exactly there something is missing you
see we can understand its error I'd
understand but something is missing
bytes are missing and those bytes are
consistently consistently missing from
the entire file so although we know we
are there we still can't analyze this
thing until we will be able to fill
those missing bytes and now we are
trying to understand what is this thing
there are a lot of options all of them
are crazy but the least craziest option
is to understand that this thing is
another form of compression because yeah
it's just it has to be there is no other
option it's really bad compression
because when we try to compress this
thing with zealey before for example we
get 80% better compression and the thing
is that we know that we have Z live in
the printer because we see the strings
to it so why would you use this
compression I don't know but it must be
a compression and now let's try to
analyze this thing together here so this
is one of the snippets I just showed you
before and let's try to analyze it
basically it's composed of two parts one
part is ASCII characters stuff that we
can read right and the other part is non
ASCII characters stuff that we can't
read those non ASCII characters are
actually the missing bytes that we have
and we need to understand how to you
know understand what they are so what we
do is just take this byte view right and
take all the ASCII characters out of it
and now we are left with with our
missing bytes
now if you stir this long enough you
will start seeing a pattern and let me
help you a bit with this because you see
this thing is composed of single bites
and double bites right and the distance
between the single bites looks
suspiciously pattern ish I would say
like 8 bites 9 bites nine bike eight
flights and now try to look at this for
a second from a different perspective so
from this perspective the pattern starts
seeing being more clear right because
you see the F 7 and F 7 they look the
same the F F and F F they look the same
but what does it mean well to understand
that you need to sharpen your binary
view for a second and if you understand
that F F for example is just 8 one bit
right and if you do this consistently
for every chunk that you have here you
will see the pattern and the pattern is
that the zero bit always falls within
this 2 bytes hole and that practically
means that the first bite is just a
bitmap describing the next the following
8 bytes so this is all 9 by chunks and
the first byte is just a map of the of
the following 8 bytes that's amazing so
now we understand what is 1 byte 1 bytes
are and all we need to do is to
understand this 2 bytes what are those 2
bytes and they must be replaced for some
characters but what are the replaced 4
that's a big question it took us some
time to understand that and if you know
anything about compression you know that
you don't have a lot of options here it
can either be a forward or backward
pointer it could be some kind of
dictionary or it could be a sliding
window now we could pretty easily say
that it's not a forward and backward
pointer and it's also not a dictionary
because we try to find references with
from within our file and we can't so the
only valid option will be that this
thing is a sliding window right and
equipped with this information we go to
our favorite place to Google and in some
dark corner of the internet we find this
wiki strange wiki page defining
something called the soft disk library
format and this thing within it has a
compression algorithm that looks really
familiar and it looks really like ours
I mean really really like ours I mean it
looks exactly like our compression
exactly the same thing we find it really
funny and the thing is that this thing
anybody knows what soft disk is so it
turns out that this compression
algorithm was invented by soft disk and
it was used once in history once in the
past you will never guess where that's
because it was used in Commander Keen
yeah now how did this make its way into
an HP printer I have no idea but it did
so if you want to follow up on that feel
free and now once we have we're equipped
with this information we actually know
what those two bytes are I mean they are
just composed of you know this this
bitmap which stands for two values a
window location and a data length and
that's basically all the information we
required in order to open this thing let
me show you how it works so we have an
input text and output text and a sliding
window and let's try to compress the
string here ABCD efg so what we do is
the first byte as I said is a bitmap so
we just leave it open for now we don't
know what the value will be and we start
working so a we write it bowling in the
output text and the sliding windows aims
for BCD and then we get to a a is
already present in the sliding window so
we don't need to write it in the output
text and then B again is just following
a and then when we eat E we just write 0
0 0 2 that means go to the sliding
window at position 0 and take the first
2 bytes that's that's the replacement
that we were looking for right and then
we continue e f g and once we have that
we can just put our bitmap here see that
the the replacement was at this position
and we have our bitmap that's pretty
easy looking at that way of course when
you're doing it in Reverse it's kind of
a bit more tricky but with this we were
able to open the fillmore file and now
we have a full finger file that we
finally finally analyze and now that we
have that we need to understand what
operating system is this monster using
well we spent quite a few time on that
but let me give you a brief explanation
so basically this thing as an operating
system called tread X it's a real-time
operating system and the CPU is running
on his arm nine big-endian something
really sexy and then there's some system
and stuff here some common libraries and
tasks which are the rough equivalent of
processes in normal operating systems
now the for system we have two-stage
bootloader and some networking
functionality some other stuff we have a
lot of common libraries just common
libraries and then we have tasks and
once we have this picture in mind we
know that we have to focus on these
specific tasks because this is what
we're looking for TTD facts log t modem
all the rest we can pretty much put a
side right so we need to start analyzing
them but just a second before we do that
we noticed something that looks fishy
you see this thing has a spider monkey
library now if you're not familiar with
this spider monkey is the most Xena
implementation of JavaScript it's used
in Firefox and we were thinking to
ourselves why would the printer use
JavaScript it makes absolutely no sense
and we were intrigued by this question
so we tried looking at where does this
thing implement JavaScript and it turns
out that the answer is simple it uses
that in a feature called pack pac-10 for
proxy Auto configuration it uses
JavaScript in order to auto configure
proxy is a pretty pretty common thing
and the thing is that the top layer
functionality of this thing was written
by HP and when we're looking at this top
layer functionality we see this this
thing before it does the functionality
it contacts this URL fake URL one two
three four comm it does nothing with it
it just it just contacts to it and and
that's it like some sort of sanity test
maybe I don't know but the interesting
is thing is does any
I know who owns the domain fake URL 1 2
3 4 dot com any guesses how did you know
yes it wasn't registered so we just
registered this domain so if anybody is
interested in a domain please contact me
I have a very good price for this domain
basically every HP printer in the world
now connects to my domain so that's
really nice and now after we've done all
that we need to actually start looking
at fax and for that I will hand it over
to a young so I'm finished messing
around
SpiderMonkey we can actually focus on T
30 T 30 the standard defines the fax for
a call it's called itu-t recommendation
T 14 in its full name the son defined
the procedures and faces and messages
needed in order to send receive a fax
document it's actually a huge standard
it has a PDF we've all 300 pages we read
through it all and it's complicated
under standard itself was first design
on 1995 and it was last updated move in
a decade ago so from our perspective it
was like it's an old standard it's
complicated we're going to find
vulnerabilities in it while you read
through the standard we started to
reverse-engineer the t30 state machine
in the film were and you can look to see
how it looks like
don't let this graph you folio as most
of the code blocks you see over there
contains additional state machines
inside them and this means we're going
to have a pretty rough job reversing it
as if that wasn't enough he turns out
the femur heavily relies on function
pointers and global variables and it's
going to be a real mess to statically
reverse engineering this thing so we
decided to change tactics we are going
to use dynamic reverse engineering who
will need a debugger
so how can you debug a printer we can't
connect to it yaniv already said but we
try to connect to the JTAG and the
serial port but that word really helpful
we then try to look for ability in gdb
stuff we could connect to but we
couldn't find one either at this point
we should remember that I can't simply
load a debugger because we don't have
any control over the execution flow and
even if we could load a debugger the
printer uses the hardware watchdog this
soon as the CPU will halt or enter a
netlist loop the watchdog will trigger a
reboot and a breakpoint usually halts
the program so we can simply hit
breakpoints we are the watchdog kicking
us out at this point we decided to split
it the parts if we could find a code
execution vulnerability we could try to
exploit it and load the debugger at this
point we had a stroke of luck actually
we believe that luck is an important
part of every research project and we
sure had our stroke of luck on the 19th
of July send your publish the convenor
ability called devil's Ivy Davis IV is
actually a remote code execution
vulnerability in the jisub open source
library embedded devices in the art
window included tend to implement
embedded web server inside them so you
could manage and configure your embedded
device in our case the printer uses G
soap in its web server after we dug in a
bit deeper we saw that we had a jackpot
our Peter is fun about the David's IV
and we now have how I debugging
vulnerability so for those of you who
are not familiar with Evans IV this is a
relevant piece of code and here is the
vulnerability itself the bad part about
this vulnerability is that it's assigned
in detail under flow and this means we
need to send roughly 2gb bytes of data
in order to exploit it I don't know if
you're familiar with the daily weights
of printers
however Twitter's are pretty slow so
after many optimization rounds
we need to reduce the transmission time
to roughly seven minutes so it's
successful exploit took us seven minutes
and this practically signals the end of
our stalker flock because our exploit
had several side effects on top of them
so after each successful exploit we're
going to have a grace period of three to
ten minutes and then the printer crashes
so we waited a lot of seven minutes you
know research but at least we have an
ability we can try to use it for you
bugging it's better than nothing so we
had pretty much we had several debugging
challenges so we need to focus up
originally we wanted to read ram in
right round soak a dynamically
reverse-engineer the t30 state machine
so now we have a control of the
execution flow we can use there is ivy
we can try to exploit it in order to
load a debugger phone once loaded we'll
need to tell the MP you what our
debugger is worthy of execution so we'd
get its privileges and when we start
executing our debugger we need to
actually install it and blend it inside
the firmware address space because we
want to connect to this debugger and it
will you don't want it to crash the
printer so it should natively blend in
signed a few more at this space we
couldn't find any known debugger we know
that does it and my battle always tells
me to stop reinventing the wheel and is
correct because wheels are not very
useful so we reinvented a debugger
instead so meat scout scout is an
instruction based debugger but we've
developed it currently supports Intel
CPUs as well as RM and in fact it even
supports aren't thumb mode I don't
really like this mode but that's what
the printer uses so you get it as a
bonus on a previous research we use
actually a prototype version of Scout in
a Linux kernel environment in which we
loaded Scout is a Linux kernel driver to
debug RPE
this time of
you scout in its embedded environment in
this environment we use Scout with a
fully position independent compilation
it actually uses its own global of the
table when we try to locate and execute
functions from the firmware itself all
you have to do in order to use Scout is
to compile it and supplied with the
addresses in the framework of usual
framer functions such as socket bind mem
copy or even sleep once compiled you
throw the compiled binary Sauer inside
the other space of your target and you
have it once executed Scout will create
a network server and wait for
instructions because it's an instruction
based debugger by remotely connecting
that the newly created network server we
can now issue instructions to read Ram
write RAM or any other extension you
wish to implement it's extendable in
checkpoint visits you believe in sharing
with the community so we can find Scout
in our github account it includes an
embedded environment tutorials and even
the Linux kernel driver we'll use for
previous research at this point of the
topic we call it many different subjects
but you haven't covered yet the most
important thing how facts actually works
using Scout we were able to dynamically
reverse-engineer the framework so let us
now tell you how facts actually works in
order to set of facts I need a fax
machine it's going to be sent to the
receivers modem the model will transfer
packets to the CPU which handles the t30
state machine and later on the data will
be handled for processing and printing
when we start interacting between both
of the modems we have Network
interaction we have probing and raging
we have a equalizer and echo canceller
and we have additional trainings you
should be quite familiar of these four
phases they actually sound like this
what would be actually done was to
create an HDL set on using this hdl-c
tunnel we are able now to send our teeth
or deep pockets as hdl-c data grounds
from our fax machine to the receive a
fax machine
t30 itself has many faces of its own on
face a we send our caller ID it's 20
bytes stream we can send whatever we
want
on face bo we negotiate our capabilities
and facey is the most important phase of
them all because here we actually send
the data itself so our document is going
to be sent line by line page by page
until it finally receive and at face D
we finish we send the Ox we receive
Zacks and that's it so let us now see
how a normal black and white fat
document is going to be sent for the
swallow call so here's our document it
will go through the HPLC tunnel the data
will be transferred using phase C and
the received result looks like this we
actually send the data of a tiff file
format a compressed in g3 of G for
compression layers and if you think what
something here is missing then you're
correct we can't cut all the heroes of
the defile the printer actually builds
them itself using data we negotiated on
phase a and phase B so from an attackers
perspective these are partially bad news
there are many vulnerabilities and TIFF
parsers however they usually require us
to control the hero this time we only
control the data itself so we're a bit
limited and after we finished building
up and processing the TIFF file it's
going to be sent for printing you know
because that's what normal people do
with fax documents and here's where it
becomes really interesting because we
figured out where T 30 had several
extensions for it and one of the
extensions can guess well the extension
is color extension the
I didn't know that faxes can be colorful
but it's a thing so let's see how a
colorful fax is going to be sent we have
here our fax documents which will travel
through the atlc tunnel using Phase II
of the t-34 the call and the receive
result will be a jpg file this time we
control the entire JPEG file its headers
and data because the colorful fax is in
fact a fully functional JPEG file so we
received 80 file with a black and white
fax and a JPEG file with colourful fax
both will be sent for printing now that
we finally understood how fax even works
where we should look for vulnerabilities
in it so all of the layers we showed
earlier can contain vulnerabilities we
have complicated state machines we
exchanged strings were several
decompression layers and we have two
different file formats we need two parts
we decided that the most convenient
layer of them all will be the
application one and more specifically
the JPEG parcel because we can fully
control the entire JPEG file so we have
a much better attack surface let us now
see how Jake your viola actually looks
like so this is a JPEG file it stands
for it finds a colorful image and the
most important thing is that JPEG
consists of markers you have a starting
after which we have an additional
marker with its opcode link field and
data after which you have a Malkiel with
its opcode length and data and so on and
so on and you finish with a marker now
we know how big a file actually looks
like let's zoom in on one such marker
specific marker is going to present a
compression table we define a forever
for compression matrix to efficiently
compress our specific document in T
files you use other tables and
design and fixed and JPEG files you can
use your own compression table for a
specific image Namaqua itself looks like
this you have our opcode or length field
the 4x4 matrix and our data if you'll
sue me in a bit deeper we can see that
the values of four or four matrix are
going to be accumulated together the
matrix is supposed to be really sparse
as you can see over there most of these
zeros some one some twos the accumulated
value is going to be the length field
for the data inside a marker in this
case we have our data is six so we're
going to have six data bytes the data
byte is of themselves are going to be
copied into a small array located on the
stack so let's um grab a bit we're going
to sum all of the values you know
forward for matrix the length field will
be six in this case and six bytes are
going to be copied into our local stack
buffer as so at this point we're like
over the facts because what will happen
if we'll use large values inside our
matrix we have sixteen bytes you know
four by four matrix and we're going to
send them all up to roughly four
kilobyte and four kilobytes of data are
going to be copy into a small stack
buffer of size 256 bytes so that's be
ideas for the frame where we have an
overflow now that we found our
vulnerability it's still stuck based
buffer overflow let us do you have any
sort of constraints because we simply
copy data from our file to the stock
buffer where have no constraints or
forbidden bytes we can use null by it's
not a skew by its whatever bytes you
choose we can use up to four kilobytes
of data and we can control the length so
we can we actually used in our exploit
roughly two K so it's controllable and
since we actually sent a large JPEG file
we can embed inside it much more data to
be
layer so we can use roughly four K for
exploit and our x-ray can load enormous
amount of data from the fax itself so we
could continue on at this point we have
a vulnerability let us now see what
bypass we should use for operating
system security mitigations no not
really because it's a real-time
operating system all of the addresses
are speaks with no stack Canaries all
the tests share the same address space
we run in the highest of privileges so
it's it's an 80s party and it couldn't
be easier once we found a vulnerability
is we contacted HP and we started a
responsible disclosure process we
actually flew over there to HP's campus
to help them we demonstrated a
vulnerability and we help them catch it
it was quite interesting because at
first we were told to fly to Portland
and very no HP offices in Portland so we
talked to them a bit more and they told
you needed we I should fly to Vancouver
and we were like Vancouver in Canada so
I flew the Portland and I'd will to
Vancouver Washington and we help them
fix it and if you were to their black
hat I was the bacchanal first time this
year you couldn't miss a huge booth of
HP we're using the wolf or the fixer
this year so we don't really know the HP
really cares about the security of its
product so we got an official yeah see
the ease from HP here the two CVEs
they're both way that is critical with a
CVS core of nine point eight out of ten
so that's quite rare maybe even familiar
with these two CVEs because they got
several media attention in the past week
so here's the official response from HP
when HP learned of the issue we were
quickly to provide updates Michigan
risks HP take security seriously in
courses customers the cutest systems
updated to protect against Patel
seven abilities and once we finish this
this is a good time for our live demo
[Applause]
okay thank you so we don't have an
office a lot of time let's see this
thing in action so we brought you here
printer Def Con could supply us with
phone lines so we just brought our own
phone thing and then we have the
attacker attack your laptop over there
and we're sending our fax now yeah good
and our answer in two rings take a look
at the LCD screen of the of the printer
receiving fax from malicious attacker if
you can relive so if you see these facts
run away and should be here now
yeah faxes are slow sorry for that yeah
fax received now the JPEG parsing is
going on and basically we have control
of the printer so this is our logo and
that means the printer is ours thank you
thank you but but we have we have we
have something else because now that we
have control over the printer it's not
enough we want to show that we can
propagate from the printer to the rest
of the network and basically what we did
is to embed eternal blue that leaked NSA
exploit within our fax and now this
printer once it what's it identifies any
connected computer you just try to
exploit it and here I'll connect if you
look at the laptop for a second then you
will see a calque popping
so we did it it was a long research let
me tell you but it was successful we
think this is groundbreaking I hope you
feel the same
and now let's sum up with some
conclusions if you'll switch back to the
presentation yeah thank you so
conclusions or PSTN is still a valid
attack surface even in 2018 facts can be
used as a gateway to internal networks
and another thing is that all in
outdated protocols are probably bad for
you so keep an eye for them and now
probably you're asking yourselves what
can you do well you can do some stuff
you can patch your printers as we said
HP published patches for these specific
nor abilities you can find them in this
URL here and instructions from HP to and
did identify by the way this works for
any HP Officejet printer in inkjet like
80 or 100 models of them so make sure
your another thing is don't connect fax
if you don't if you don't need it right
and if you do not need to connect fax
then make sure to segregate your
printers so they won't be connected to
the rest of the network so if somebody
manages to take over your printers at
least the risk will be contained within
the printer and you won't be able to
propagate to the rest of the network now
these are all really good suggestions
but really the best suggestions are the
best suggestion I have to give you today
is please stop using fax
[Applause]
and now we really couldn't do a lot of
this research if it wasn't for our
wonderful friends so they helped us
physically technically and mentally
throughout the entire process of this
research so they deserve some some
clapping thank you thank them and one
specific guy Ian I also helped us a lot
in the few more thing and that's
practically it so thank you very much
and if you want to follow us please
follow us on Twitter read our stuff on
the on our blog and thank you very much
for coming to this talk
[Applause]